we're told the polynomial p of x which
is equal to this has a known factor of x
plus 6.
rewrite p of x as a product of linear
factors pause this video and see if you
can have a go at that
all right now let's work on this
together because they give us one of the
factors what we can do is say hey what
happens if i divide x plus 6 into p of x
what do i have left over it looks like
i'm still going to have a quadratic and
then i'll probably have to factor that
somehow to get a product of linear
factors so let's get going
so if i were to try to figure out what x
plus 6 divided into
x to the third plus 9 x squared
and now we're going to have to be
careful you might be tempted to just
write minus 108 there but then this gets
tricky because you have your third
degree column your second degree column
you need your first degree column but
you just put your zero degree your
constant column here so to make sure we
have good hygiene we could write plus 0x
and i encourage you to actually always
do this if you're writing out a
polynomial so that you don't skip that
place so to speak
minus
108.
and so then you say all right let's look
at the highest degree terms
x goes into x to the third
x squared times
x squared times 6 is 6 x squared x
squared times x is x to the third we
want to subtract we've done this
multiple times so i'm going a little bit
faster than normal
those cancel out 9x squared minus 6x
squared is 3x squared bring down that 0x
and then how many times does x go into
3x squared well it goes 3x times and we
would write it in this column and notice
if we didn't keep this column for our
first degree terms we'd be kind of
confused where to write that 3x right
about now
and so 3x plus times 6 i should say is
18x 3x times x is 3x squared we want to
subtract what we have in that i guess
that color is move light purple not sure
and so we get
3x squared's cancel out and then 0x
minus 18x is negative 18x
bring down
that negative 108.
and so
then we have
x goes into
negative eighteen x
negative eighteen times
negative eighteen times six
is
negative one hundred and eight that's
working out nicely negative eighteen
times x is negative 18 x
and then we want to subtract what we
have in this not so pleasant brown color
and so i will
multiply them both by negative and so i
am left with zero everything just
cancels out
and so i can rewrite p of x
i can rewrite p of x as being equal to
x plus 6
times x squared plus 3x minus 18 but i'm
not done yet because this is not a
linear factor this is still quadratic so
let's see can i think of two numbers
that add up to 3 and then when i
multiply i get negative 18. so they'll
need different signs
and then the obvious one
is is
positive 6 and negative 3. and if that
what i just did seems like voodoo to you
i encourage you to review factoring
polynomials
but this i can rewrite because negative
6
plus or actually i should say positive 6
plus negative 3 is equal to 3 and then
positive 6 times negative 3 is equal to
negative 18. so i can rewrite this as x
plus 6
times
x plus six
times
x
minus three
and so there we have it we have a
product of linear factors and we are
done